a lot of people have talked about
China's growing role in Africa I
personally am not particularly either
upset or surprised by this because
realistically what's going on is simply
the increased role that china is playing
in the globe at large as you would
expect a growing economic power to play
and it's focused on resource plays it's
focused on buying up and securing energy
sources and materials and various things
that will fuel the continued growth of
the Chinese economy and it's exactly
what you'd expect it certainly has some
adverse consequences because since the
Chinese don't care about various kinds
of human rights issues and they don't
care about political freedoms they're
more than happy to deal with dictators
they're more than happy to overlook all
sorts of trouble if it if their
particular immediate needs are taken
care of but you know what in the long
run the Chinese might well find that
stability and sustainably healthy viable
local communities and polities are in
their best interest as well